hello and welcome to the CEO playing
bass ook yeah okay yeah he wished me
good luck so might as well return that
okay so we've got the modern main line
of the petrov that's at least how I
called it visually aphorism less trendy
variation a usual frequent argument
against it is it's the line with short
castling but this is not what I usually
want to do in this opening it is not a
big deal really black can quite easily
play in the same way as against Bishop
III and it does not really make a huge
difference
yeah this is the sea takes lines not
considered to be very dangerous but they
are obviously very solid yeah for what
you're not going to get much with white
what's not going to be any trouble and
one interesting question is always if
you want to play d65
or not I usually advocate to do that I
can also I could have played actually
the move c6 and thinking about it a
little bit maybe that was better but
okay it's not a huge issue
yeah this is just equal white has a
small symbolic advantage but it's really
not much more than that
he has got if you rate the main backbone
of the pawn structure he'll call these
the main points then he's got to Betty
Bishop okay so let's see yeah I probably
have to do that for rook e8 and Bishop
d7
Ruki age this actually you should have
five yeah it's not it's not a huge deal
okay what I should not do is playing a
six that would be a wrong idea
yeah it just is just very cool he does
not have anything better than trading
really and now what are you going to do
we have put this on the dark square I
guess
so I should have played a five should
have played a five that would have been
a little bit better
- with Wendy five I mean it is just
equal also if I would have played a five
I'm not claiming I would have had an
advantage but it would have been a lot
would have been a bit easier
mm-hmm okay so you're going to play g5
or what's this what's the deal I mean
it's very tough to imagine anything else
than the draw here yeah the problem is
that white can simply just stay and do
absolutely nothing
it would be easiest film just to take
one c5 and now he has to take okay so if
I take C three here is that something I
take C six check goes back clay Bishop
c4 don't think it works that's
unfortunate
can we do something
King f 2 F 4 hmm I can take it would
also probably F [ __ ] it - king C 3
wins right yeah yes it should have been
a draw but you can always continue great
it's a draw
but yeah so um in this kind of situation
I'm taking with the pawn is just very
conservative but it's also tough
[Music]
yeah d5 yeah it's it's again it's a
simple simple thing to do and white
still has a symbolic advantage as you
see that the engine likes white and it's
understandable but it's just not
something where I you can typically win
it's just probably going to be drawn
yeah this is your King takes you three
and there's some activity in the chat to
this game I'm going to check this so I
think here we we were talking about just
not much happening and I should
definitely sorry I should definitely
play 85 and make before a little bit so
we had this one and it's I think it's
still equal ish even even though the
engine gives 0.7 if you just stay and do
absolutely nothing it could be a draw
yeah it's it's this is a funny funny
thing yeah like g5 take take oh that's
really not much happening not even sure
that played g5 so king b6 Bishop d3 and
again we're just talking about equal I
would have chicken with the C pawn yeah
I agree what the engine says I still
think it's a draw but
you
sorry about that at least I could mute
them micro so yeah this is equal and
tear King to X III was mentioned I don't
think it worked though yeah I think why
this is quicker right and they had
record firms
all of a sudden I got this
sneezing urge and I think oh I thought I
thought I was winning here actually I
have five so you can still take and draw
okay can you have two is it yeah it's
not know where you do this but okay this
is this is still a drama here and f6 our
six and the draw okay okay okay
yeah that is that sets big yeah that's
very important yeah I don't win that's
to draw and the most important thing is
that after King takes there's f4
preventing me from going here so this is
just a draw so I thought that this would
actually lose but it doesn't
what are you sure the engine oh so that
it spoiled it or what King takes so how
am i winning now I don't see it you know
it says draw very weird
I'm very real or the engine is scheming
here it's a wrong you know it know it
says not fine Seadrill know it finds the
draw yeah okay so that should have been
into operating this ending what you can
the end always post problems thanks a
lot guys thanks for watching